We can't prove that the null hypothesis is true. We can only obtain evidence to
reject the null hypothesis. Let's take a simple example. Let's say, our null
hypothesis is that most dogs have four legs. And we define most as more than
50% of dogs. This 50% is analogous to our alpha level where we set our
criterion for making a decision. Our alternative hypothesis is that most dogs
have less than four legs. Note that this is like a one tailed test. Where we're
not guessing that most dogs have a different amount than four legs. We're
guessing most dogs have less, so there's a direction. Now let's say we sample
10 dogs and find that all of them have four legs. Did we prove that the null
hypothesis is true, that most dogs have four legs?